[Music]
it was the highest-rated show of its era
the most talked about pop culture event
of the decade and by the end of its
final seasons one of the biggest
letdowns in TV history or have brand the
broken protector of the realm Oh
Game of Thrones season 6 through 8 the
show based on George RR Martin's
doorstop novels returns but since they
already burned through those they're
going off an outline and boy does it
feel that way we're after one mixed
season that still pulled off some major
highs the last two shortened ones
scramble to tie everything up real quick
because the show runners either got
bored burnt out or bitter that no one
liked their slavery idea
featuring huge revelations that never
really pay off you know the true king so
on new king has chosen to send you to
the Nights Watch relationships that took
years to develop turning on a dime stay
with me and characters who straight-up
forgot their best friends or forgot they
have magic shape-shifting powers or for
God who they're at war with Danny kind
of forgot about the iron fleet she
forgot for God the biggest Navy in
Westeros existed admit it this whole
show was an elaborate plot for you to
meet ed Sheeran pretty song winter has
come to King's Landing so they moved the
entire city to the desert they're our
main players will finally collide to see
who will sit on the Iron Throne will the
reign of Queen Cersei continue or will
she just stare out the window
[Music]
we'll Daenerys continued our surgical
attacks against the ruling class or will
she 420blaze the world when her nephew
won't give her the D no war will Jon
Snow do anything my watch is ended
I'm tired of fighting I never wanted a
crown don't want it I never wanted it I
told you I don't want it I don't want it
I never have no the winner at the end of
it all is the character with the best
story and who has a better story and
brand the broken bread brand the
creepy-ass kid how about like literally
anyone else it's ok epic voice guy
remember it's just a trainer get hyped
up get sell show sellitto say goodbye to
the complex heroes you come to love and
say hello to their one-dimensional
look-alikes
like varus but of the dick joke if I
lost my cried drink all the time I don't
think it's a true qualification as I'm
sure you'd agree you should consider
yourself lucky least your balls run
freeze off because you have no cook
Littlefinger Lord at that one balcony in
Winterfell
[Music]
or the Arias dark reunion tour lady
stock you came home you still have it
needle hello hope I am area lady Stark
don't call me that he's had with me
again and here we are you left me to die
first I robbed you while the shows were
lively great villains backslide from the
Joffrey ask Ramsay Bolton to the
mysterious night king who after all your
fan theories really was just some dude
the Keebler Elf stabbed to a tree to
this soggy pick-up artist who stole the
Dragons plot armor for himself have to
be honest he's making me hot what Tim
Burton movie is historic from I take a
dozen high Sparrow lectures evermore the
emo pringles guy we have weak vain
creatures we live only by the mothers
must truly everyone ok nevermind but
screw characters because Game of Thrones
can still deliver some amazing visual
spectacles as soon as you remember how
to crank the brightness on your TV there
we go from the claustrophobic terror of
the Battle of the bastards to the ground
level chaos of the Battle of King's
Landing to eight guys waiting for help
on a frozen pond we have to burn his
body oh now you use the fire sword rest
assured that in the later seasons
everything will look awesome and no one
you really care about is gonna die
fine
see good as new so lick your wounds for
the show that managed to both limb and
sprint to the finish line just hold the
door on giving it Cropp for not ending
the way you thought they can't please
everybody or four characters teleporting
around they ought to converge at some
point or even all the huge strategic
blunders mistakes aren't the same as
potholes no be grateful for a show
that's given us the last communal
experience in our divided world
crapping on the final seasons of Game of
Thrones together Oh
gonna miss you dumb show god yeah yeah
come on I don't need you no I'm not
gonna watch the spin-offs you crazy
starring Jack Sparrow a Lannister always
looks on the bright side I think we
might live I do hear to him surely
there's some good news lurking somewhere
you should both be happy as well thank
you I feel much better yes my queen
I'm loyal to my queen I am loyal to my
queen I obey my queens commands I kill
the Queen's enemies the new Prince of
Dorne I guess I don't know doesn't
matter
Snow Fairy strikland strikland in a
fantasy world
Harry Strickland sells propane and
propane accessories all right our next
comedian you might have seen in north of
the wall give it up for tormund
Giantsbane no it's one of the you
cowards
in my pants I saw your pecker what kind
of God would have a Becca that small you
weigh as much as two fleas
stay back he's got blue eyes I've always
had blue eyes
you're a lucky man fanservice thought he
might still be rolling crap service hmm
you're just gonna murder me on this
murder show
[Music]
shivers
good boy who's a good boy we never
forget you my widdle pump less nudie
than ever but still
no one wants to see that or that and
definitely not that we known her since
she was 14 years ago
trying to impress your impossible to
impress dad I won't apologize for trying
to rescue Thiel and where is he your
best hunters they obviously had help
I didn't think lady Sansa killed him all
by herself I managed to stay in a soft
I'm fat spending your life reading about
the achievements of better men do we
have the men I don't have an army their
Army's gone our Army's gone do we have
enough men how many men do we have in
the north to fight 10,000 less fewer we
need every man we can get we don't have
the numbers we don't have the numbers we
don't have the numbers I don't have
enough men don't have the men you don't
have the men you said you don't have
enough men we need more men we need more
men we need more men we're looking to
have this money man it's not enough oh
it's not enough everything characters
have ever done wrong strangled my lover
I shot my own father with a crossbow
I've betrayed my queen and pushed a boy
out at our window crippled him for life
I strangled my cousin with my own hands
we burned her at the stake she was good
she was kind and yeah Gilda I made a
terrible mistake
I made a mistake a horrible mistake I
underestimated a stranger you don't know
the saints I've done I did unspeakable
things I've done plenty of things that I
regret how compared to me you haven't
and kid hairline I mean Harrington I'm
never gonna unsee that a slog of ice and
fire
I don't care how many people Danny bites
on fire the hound will always have the
sickest burns you're getting okay he's
not thank you for watching this video
but did you know we also make other
videos with just one click you could be
watching one of those videos now hold
the door hold the door Hodor it's going
to be legend wait for it and I hope
you're not lactose intolerant because
the second half of that word is dairy
legendary